يسجل في السعوديه والعالم اليوم حدث
تاريخي يشهد انطلاق اول رائده فضاء سعوديه
عربيه هي ريانه برناوي وكذلك علي القرني
الذي يعد ايضا اول رائد فضاء سعودي يصل
الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه الهيئه السعوديه
للفضاء اكدت جاهزيه صاروخ فالكون تسعه
ومركبه دراغون على منصه الاطلاق في
فلوريدا استعدادا طبعا لنقل طاقم مهمه اي
اكس اثنان والتي تضم رائدي الفضاء
السعوديين ذكرت الهيئه ان هذه الرحله تاتي
ضمن برنامج السعوديه لرواد الفضاء الذي تم
اطلاقه في سبتمبر من العام 2020
وتتضمن اجراء اربعه عشره تجربه بحثيه
علميه رائده في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى كما
تعزز نتائج الابحاث ستعزز نتائج الابحاث
مكانه المملكه عالميا في مجال استكشاف
الفضاء وخدمه البشريه وتؤكد دور مراكز
الابحاث السعوديه في احداث تاثير في عدد
من المجالات كالصحه الاستدامه وايضا تقنيه
الفضاء تضع هذه الرحله تضع السعوديه كاحدى
الدول القليله في العالم التي تتمكن من
ارسال رائدي فضاء من الجنسيه نفسها على
متن محطه الفضاء الدوليه وفي الوقت نفسه
اتمنى مؤخرا اجمال التدريبات المتعلقه
بالرحله وكانت بشكل عام التدريب على
المهام اليوميه التشغيليه لمحطه الفضاء
الدوليه تدربنا على مركزين الابحاث
الاوروبي والياباني كذلك
التدريبات وجملتا على كيفيه التعايش داخل
المحطه الفضاء الدوليه وكذلك محاكاه
للانطلاق والعوده التدرب على الادوات اللي
بنستخدمها ان شاء الله في الابحاث العلميه
والابحاث
العمليه ان شاء الله على متن المحطه
فهذه التدريبات بشكل عام تثبت او او
تمكننا من القدره على النجاح في هذه
المهمه وكذلك بعد المهمه ان شاء الله نعود
الى ارض الوطن محققين جميع الاهداف
المرجوه من هذه الرحله
اكيد استاذ اصلا مهمتنا بالاساس هي مهمه
علميه فباذن الله سنقوم باجراء 14 تجربه
علميه بحثيه رائده يعني لاول مره في
التاريخ باذن الله هذه التجارب تعنى
بمجالات متعدده اولها هي ثلاث تجارب
توعويه تعليميه ستكون
لها علاقه بالتعاون مع الطلاب فهذه
التجارب كلها هدفها تحفيز الطلاب وتحفيز
الفضول لديهم في مجال الفضاء وباذن الله
سنقوم باجراء اربع تجارب علميه لها علاقه
بالخلايا المناعيه وهذه باذن الله حتكون
اول مره في التاريخ سنقوم بزراعه خلايا
مناعيه في بيئه الجاذبيه الصغرى بحيث انه
نزرع الخلايا ونضيف علاجات مختلفه عليها
ونشوف مدى استجابتها في بيئه الجاذبيه
الصوره وهذه البحث لاول مره يجرى في
التاريخ بدعم سمو سيدي حفظه الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات